Hello world,
it's Saroj and welcome to AI humanities.
I've spent the past few weeks reading 10 books that I'd like to share with you.
I call it AI humanities because it relates AI to various aspects of human
culture and society.
My list is sequential.
Each book will answer questions that come up from the previous book.
The average person only reads a few books a year,
but the average CEO reads four or five books a month.
Leaders are readers.
If someone spends decades accumulating knowledge on a topic,
then puts it all into a book and you can read that book in one or two days.
You can download decades of knowledge instantly.
The way I read so many books so fast is that I listened to these books as audio
books at three x speed and I scheduled my reading time usually one hour a day.
If you don't schedule your reading time,
you'll be much more likely to skip it.
So let's start with the first the master algorithm.
This was a pretty high level overview of the entire field of machine learning
aimed at the layman,
but I wouldn't say this book is meant for someone who's never even heard of
machine learning.
The first couple chapters are probably accessible to the layman,
but it's in the later chapters that the author starts detailing various
algorithms in a way that presumes at least a little bit of background knowledge.
If you want an absolute beginner book to get into machine learning like a
prerequisite to this list,
I'd recommend hands on machine learning with psychic can't learn and tensorflow.
Anyway,
what I liked most about this book was the conceptual model that was created of
the field.
The author categorized different areas of thought in machine learning into their
own respective tribes.
There are the symbolists that connectionists,
the evolutionaries,
the Bayesians and the analyzers each have their own perspective on what the
best,
most generalized smartest algorithm is.
He then goes on to actually algorithmically describe backpropagation and genetic
programming master algorithms for each of these tribes,
which was pretty cool.
Ultimately he argues that the eventual master algorithm able to learn how to do
any task is likely a combination of all of these and we are slowly getting
there.
Discovery by discovery.
I like how he makes connections between these separate methodologies saying that
no matter what technique we use,
all of them are meant to do the same.
Three things represent,
evaluate and optimize.
Reading.
The master algorithm got me thinking more about the future of Ai.
If we did create the master algorithm,
how would we use it as a species?
What would the future look like?
And that led me to the book life 3.0 by MIT professor and physicist Max Tegmark.
Tegmark goes on to describe life 1.0 as biological evolution life 2.0 as
cultural evolution and life 3.0 as tech evolution.
My favorite part of the book was the fictional story of the super intelligent AI
called prometheus's and how it was used by a company to basically conquer the
world.
It was actually plausible.
He mentioned it's using tools like AWS and gaming the stock market to
demonstrate a concrete example of how things could go wrong overall.
That's what stood out for me from the book how things could go wrong,
and that question led me to read super intelligence by Professor Nick Bostrom.
This is the book on Ai Safety,
how things could go wrong and how we can possibly stop it.
The example that sticks out above all else is his paperclip maximized your idea
that if we tell an AI to make as many paperclips as possible,
that could potentially go wrong in that the AI would then turn all matter
including humans into paperclips in order to complete its objective.
Scary stuff.
But I do think Bostrom could have been more specific in his ideas about which
algorithms in particular he fears the most and how that could happen in a
detailed way.
What entity would do this?
What would be the context?
Things like that.
In general,
the fear mongering around AI is really distracting to what the actual problem
is.
I'm not afraid of superintelligent AI.
I'm afraid of humans using AI to exploit other humans.
Technology is like fire.
It can be used to either burn us or to give us warmth.
So above all else,
apocalyptic AI is actually a problem of human morality.
Whoever creates a real AGI will decide how to use it based on their morality and
how do we even regulate morality on a global scale.
We can't even decide on what good and evil is as a species.
Thinking about morality had me reread a book from my favorite classical
philosopher,
Nicha called the beyond good and evil.
I remember during my first year at Columbia,
we had a list of philosophers that we had to read about from content to Plato,
but none of their philosophies really resonated with me.
Then I read Nicha.
He basically tore down every other philosophers conception of morality.
His base conviction is that the universe is in a constant state of change,
so absolutes like good or evil or even God are too rigid.
In fact,
they are forms of enslavement in his eyes.
In particular,
he digs into how the institution of the Church has enslaved man and hampered his
will to power this drive for freedom and domination over other things.
He criticizes how the Church has failed to truly represent Jesus,
how it demonizes flourishing in life and glorifies living an apathetic life.
Nietzsche is like the angsty teen of philosophers.
Now,
I myself am not religious,
but it did get me thinking about how religion does offer order in the midst of
the complexity and chaos of our reality by providing a set of rules to abide by
and in a world where as an ea would put it,
God is dead,
where the scientific rationality that sprung up during the age of enlightenment
triumphed over sacred revelations.
We need some sort of set of principles or rule book to live by,
especially in this information age where there's just so much data that's being
thrown at us from every angle.
So I went ahead and write a book that's currently very popular called 12 rules
for life by Dr. Jordan Peterson,
a clinical psychologist.
The book delves into a set of basic life principles that we can use to become
more disciplined,
behave better,
act with integrity and balance our lives while enjoying them as much as we can.
Each rule is simple like aim to do what is meaningful,
not convenient.
He combines ideas from Uwm,
Nietzsche or well and Freud to help make suggestions on the basis of psychology.
Now,
I don't agree with everything he says in the book and I don't endorse any one
particular political ideology because education applies to everyone.
I like how Peterson illuminates the spectrum in which all opinions and beliefs
lie.
He acknowledges that the world is not binary.
It has incredible complexity.
There are many layers to society and human nature and he mentioned that in this
information era,
we become increasingly polarized in our beliefs.
He's right about that society has become very polarized the past few years.
My theory being that it's largely due to the rise of social media to help
examine that theory.
I then read 10 reasons to delete your social media.
I,
one of my favorite authors,
Jerome Linear.
I've actually read several of his works before,
which inspired me to write my own book years ago.
Linear has technical authority.
He's one of the founders of the Internet who evangelize the power of technology
early on,
but is now one of the most critical figures when it comes to it.
Look,
I use social media and without it I wouldn't be able to give you this message so
there is a benefit to it,
but the larger idea that he argues is that social media has allowed for
industrial scale manipulation and behavioral modification in a way that's never
before been possible and Ai Algorithms both in a direct and indirect way or
polarizing society.
The best AI engineers in the world are working on ads,
figuring out how to maximize your attention.
Ai Is of course also being used to benefit humanity in a lot of ways,
but this book in particular made me want to really narrow my focus on what
exactly I personally found to be the most exciting part about Ai.
Deep minds,
Alpha fold victory.
Applying AI to biology was definitely a promising direction.
Biology in general.
It's something I felt like I needed to refresh my knowledge on.
So I read the gene,
an intimate history by doctor Mukherjee,
an oncologist.
The book takes the reader through the history of the gene and genetic research
all the way from Aristotle to crick and describes the decades of progress in
this area,
like a riveting adventure.
It was like an action movie,
an insight from one scientist on evolution that into other insights from other
scientists on how genes could work together.
I learned that a lot of things that I was so excited about regarding the
possibility of human enhancement using genetic technology had already been
talked about and debated for decades.
The atom,
the gene and the bite he argued are the three fundamental building blocks of
science and technology and the intersection of each would define progress in the
21st century like Alpha fold recently did.
One area of the book that I found particularly interesting was that there's
still so much about genetics that we don't understand.
The gene actually doesn't give us the whole story behind our actions and our
traits.
In fact,
an entire field called epigenetics,
which literally means on top of genetics refers to the information layered on
top of the sequence of letters in DNA.
It describes inheritance by mechanisms other than through the DNA sequence of
genes and that field is still evolving.
So I started looking up books on epigenetics and I came upon a book called the
physics of God.
Again,
I don't ascribe to any one religion,
I'm agnostic,
but this book was definitely eyeopening.
It aims to unify quantum mechanics,
consciousness,
neuroscience,
and genetics into one cohesive theory.
The author argues that scientific materialism has only been able to explain so
much and that there exists a holographic energy body that governs the billions
of coordinated biochemical events happening at the genetic level at every second
be a quantum entanglement.
The author points to various eastern mystical concepts about the soul from
various religions as alluding to this idea in a primitive way,
the very notion of a holographic energy body is nonmaterial.
It would live on a different plane and couldn't be empirically tested,
but it would help fill the gaps that genetics and epigenetics have yet to
explain the idea that all living things are connected to each other,
that we are more than the material machinery of our bodies.
It's a comforting idea for sure.
I'm not sure if it's true or not,
but it did get me to question the nature of reality.
More fundamentally.
Eastern and western philosophy have been separated by physical distance for
hundreds of years,
but with the Internet and better mediums of communication,
we can bring the best ideas from these disciplines together to help solve the
mysteries of the universe and in thinking about the potential for eastern
philosophy,
I picked up a copy of AI superpowers by Doctor [inaudible],
former head of Google,
China.
I really liked this book and youth,
a lot of the insights from it to make my video on AI in China.
It opened my eyes to how China is shaping AI and how the future might not
necessarily look western,
but instead be shaped by China.
The amount of AI innovation happening there is incredible and his description of
how different the market in China was fascinating.
I really liked how he avoided vague AI apocalyptic predictions and instead focus
on mass scale unemployment due to AI as the real problem that could occur.
Kai Fu believes that not all human capabilities can be replicated with AI,
that we still have something about us that's not purely mechanical and his
narrative becomes pretty emotional in some parts as he describes how he survived
cancer,
which made him appreciate his humanity that much more.
This book got me pretty hype about how much China is embracing Ai Technology and
I've never even been to China yet.
So to learn more about Chinese culture,
I rent the last book on my list,
the three body problem.
This is a wildly popular Chinese side by novel that was a few years ago,
transcribed to English for the first time and I absolutely love this book.
It got pretty technical in some parts.
She Chines explanations of physics and computing.
We're on point,
and I especially liked how he brought characters like fond NOI,
men and Einstein and Aristotle back to life in the simulated game environment to
help explain it.
Different concepts.
This book was full of big grand ideas and it allowed me to peek into Chinese
culture and that there were a lot of colloquial references to food and tradition
overall.
It helped me appreciate humanity's progress in science much more so that's it
for my list.
I hope you found it useful.
Joined the school of Ai Book Club Channel In our slack group to discuss your
ongoing thoughts with peers.
I'll give a Twitter shout out to the first wizard that finishes of my list.
Let me know when you do,
what's your favorite book?
Let me know in the comment section and please subscribe for more technology
videos.
For now.
I'm going to read Oh,
shows works,
so thanks for watching.